you two are naked a lot in the movie and
I will say shockingly you are shockingly
naked yeah in the movie that is naked as
a person could get what that means zero
clothes yes zero clothes you're York
there's no there's its full frontal
we're seeing full frontal yeah yeah very
much well we actually had to Jason and I
both had to wear a prosthetic penis yeah
in each war we yes we do in the family
we didn't share upstairs
might have been a money saver yeah yeah
I was on your turn I feel spiritually we
share a prosthetic yeah that goes
without saying yes we all do yeah well
but we were nervous about wearing them
but then once we had them on we were
like weirdly comfortable and with them
on and kind of just sauntered around the
so these are these are very realistic
yeah prosthetic pieces that fit over
your existing penises yeah and since we
are currently yes yes and so then you
were able to walk around and kind of act
like you were naked but also have the
the security to know that you're not
really naked yeah and we just sort of
gallivant it around together yeah it was
nice I mean people were you know people
thought like on the crew intellectually
people knew that these weren't our real
penises but they still treated at him
and I like we were naked in the
beginning and like people would come up
to me for instance and just be like hi
can I get you a coffee or anything like
that
I'd like avert their eyes and I was like
guys guys guys this is not my penis yeah
this is your penis this is your pee no
okay with all of our penises let's get
off that team bull I wanna point out
Jason you must have been happy because
you were given the much larger
prosthetic device yeah in the film I
don't know whose choice that was you
must have an excellent agent has the
penis I'll take it yeah no clearly I
mean yours is quite a size difference
yeah I don't know how that manifests
I'll oh I loved it I loved it it was
nice in fact well like the day that I
first had the penis applied to me I know
I was dreading it of course you lie
there they put it on with adhesive and
it's put on you and then when I stood up
for the first time actually saw it it
was really nice and fun to have it and I
have been telling orgeous Thank You Adam
and you know but it was something I was
looking forward to to having for
sometime so I couldn't wait to tell this
movie came out for my wife is he it so I
actually tried to take a selfie but it
didn't work so that I had some of the
hair and makeup lady L she took a few
photos of me fully naked and we didn't
get the lighting quite right so then we
took like three or four and of me and
then I text them to my wife and she
thought it was great you so this is you
with the the new-and-improved
yeah and and and and and you send it to
her you texted a tour and it was great
and I've never done anything like that
before and and I didn't I don't know a
lot about naked photos texting but I
will say that a few days after we had
refuting I went to my daughter's school
for her multicultural fair and at the
time my wife and I had just had a six
week old baby and the principal of the
school came up to me and she said how's
it going how how are you and your wife
doing has the baby I said oh it's
wonderful thank you so much you should
do you have any pictures I could see and
I said I said yes I do
yes I do here and I just don't know how
the phones work so well so I turned on
we were like this and I hit I photo and
I opened it and the first thing that
comes up is the last picture taken which
is me completely naked with a nine and a
half
we have that there it is
[Applause]
because to this day to this day like I
was like swiping I mean what did she do
did she freak out well I don't know cuz
it was sunny I was that there was a
glare and I did eventually get off those
there were a bunch like I was you know a
bunch of photos and we got to my some
cute photos my daughter but then to this
day I'm not quite sure like it's a weird
tension like I don't know like how do I
bring it up maybe tonight she'll see
this and we can get it out there but I
will say that ever since that point like
when we have parent-teacher conferences
it's a breeze yeah we walk in there and
like with teachers are like your
daughter's doing great and we're have
any problems and you got it right how
we're happy you guys were at the school
you got a 20% discount on tuition as
well can't help but think she saw the
picture